[Music]
how how um how much money
do you think a woman who goes to walmart
has and what do you think she's there to
buy 17
no tiny house no you mean like carrying
like the average female buyer at walmart
so how much she has to spend yeah fifty
seven dollars my ziplock bag for
sandwiches 150 bucks no three hundred
dollars and she's probably 80 just to
buy a vacuum because she didn't do her
job good can you give us some parameters
hey that's a good guess right now four
hundred dollars so she could buy a gun
no i gotta walk three hundred dollars in
toiletries in texas i have to say have
his back i buy bazooka there yeah three
hundred or an abram's sake
no okay [ __ ]
damn you guys are bad at guessing today
all right [ __ ] two hundred dollars in
twinkies
eight dollars buying dishwasher slump so
she can make her husband slip up on the
floor no good lord i i literally just i
thought you guys would get this
immediately but
okay so she
when did she get so bad she walked up so
this woman walks up to another woman
at a walmart self-checkout aisle i bet
they started gossiping didn't they
they they sure did
damn women and she told her i want to
buy your baby what
and that's the average shopper in
walmart they always buying babies
they're buying whatever they want price
tag already
buy it now the babies in walmart so it's
the first sale
so the 49 year old woman allegedly
offered the woman 250 000 but the mother
refused that's a good deal
then the mother child waited for the
lady to leave the store play hardball
before exiting herself where she was
then confronted by the woman where she
doubled her priced it 500 000 wow
was it was it that cute how old was the
baby how was his baby what makes her a
couple expert baby appraisal yeah that
must have been a cute baby it was a cute
baby apparently but half a million
dollar baby i'd give away a kid or two
yeah
so then
well because you eat two of them it's a
million yeah yeah you can show that
money right away so it's kind of a whack
dude depends on what kid you got already
how do you prove that you have that
money in hand
did she have right here like this yo
dude
at walmart just playing dude baby budget
airplane in the parking lot she had two
dollar bills in the [ __ ] cube yeah
like i didn't know that it's like yeah a
big block big block of it what's
everyone's serious price
for
your own baby for my first baby
baby serious surprise you asked a
question two mil
ask a questioner i think i think if you
like realistically try and think about
is already [ __ ] up but let's just go
and try and think about it even if you
sold your baby for a million i think
that you would reasonably think about
that for the rest of your life so you
have to be able to live with the
justification of the price point you
gotta be a savager so i think it's got
to be like maybe 250 million
what your kid's not that get over
yourself bro nobody's ever so bougie who
is this lady
who's this [ __ ] creepy lady that's
trying to buy someone's baby
who's gonna buy a second place baby i
[ __ ] rather chase this [ __ ] down
that's where they got the expression add
to cart you could get away cheaper at
the adoption factory
yeah this lady just like how much does a
baby cost when you adopt it can can you
search what is the average [ __ ] baby
price
i bet it's like five figures yeah the
whole the fostering and why is that
walmart supposed to be a discount shop
why is this [ __ ] paying an airplane
price for a baby yeah maybe it's the
price
maybe it's a the 85 inch screen version
of a baby but it's walmart though curved
samsung but they still got those at
walmart last truth the curved one even
like one two three i'm like okay so
nobody else is going to answer the
question what you're going to sell your
baby oh yeah [ __ ] it's 40 grand right
maybe 50. 250 million yeah 50 grand you
saw your baby well now i'm too rich
maybe a little bit more
go to sports stadium and said okay
i would never do it because it you'll
never be able to
to pay enough money to get them to leave
you alone when they come hunting for you
as it is oh that was good uh i thought
you were playing with the cameras and
the women right now
thank you very much
no you you're not gonna be like look bro
i would never do it because i love my
childhood that's what i was gonna say
that's all you're gonna say you you
never you you're not gonna be like look
rhodes half a million what the [ __ ] give
me a half a million i'll take you back
let's be real right now how much for
taika let's go
honest price honestly dude
price honestly and you have like five
you have like don't fight
hey nobody's watching but it's just us
yeah cameras are cut yeah cameras are no
[ __ ] you got to put a [ __ ] number
down not like ryan's weak-ass answer man
it's kind of hard dude you just gotta
sell it and then tell jio later you know
what i mean yeah i get it but yeah but
there's a price for that guys love their
core vets too let's [ __ ] talk though
oh man i don't know answer this and i'll
give you another question a follow-up
question say 251 million you'll be safe
i'll probably chop off one of my limbs
before i sell them
a number
man
i got another question for you
guaranteed he's gonna have a good life
how much how much for tyka when he was
an annoying fool waking you up in the
middle of the night how about that
that price is lower fresh out the womb
that's when i would sell my stuff that's
good you can't get it fucker's waking me
up too much take it for a [ __ ] 250
thousand dollars so long you're already
sleep deprived so you're like you're
kind of joking joe would not sell for
250 000 he's just trying to front joe's
good at selling low though i have to say
yep
i'm a master at selling love you know
what um everybody trying to find i would
say that it depends on supplies like
economics i like that answer
i have five kids at least i answer it's
worth your while what's your what what
was serious about your answer
what's your answer no no the question i
said name of price name price everybody
yeah everybody has a price bar and i
didn't i can't you know nobody can even
answer you guys just hating
yeah that's a serious price he had an
actual serious problem but i didn't hate
on trump i didn't hit on you want to
know what everybody else is doing i
never hate it on your property i hate it
on your price well he hit him what do
you mean i didn't have a serious play i
said 500 000 dollars if i had multiple
kids multiple that's the price that she
was giving you're making up a price her
price was 500.000 at the market you're
not you're unrealistic joe's looking at
the market you're looking at love
practical yeah we got to stop shaming
him
500 000 okay i have five kids i could
spare one i would get the most annoying
[ __ ] that cries too much fifty million
two people okay
all of them okay 250 ml
yeah okay because 50 mil that's absurd
500 grand
i have a buyer already all right pricing
yeah i have a [ __ ] buyer
what's your price what depends is my kid
jewish yeah
how does that change their equation
changes the price
they're going to pay more that's why
[Music]
i mean because you're asking a crazy ass
question right it's like it's a crazy
ass article how much would someone have
to pay you to kill your parents how can
i prove my kid's jewish i'm gonna give a
price 750 000 well if it was my dad i do
it for free
yeah
um
she's almost dying
but maybe a couple more years but you
still wouldn't do it you just wouldn't
do it
it's assumed you wouldn't do it i think
the hypothetical is the conversation
good job by the way of acting because
he's 500k he's acting like you know he
wouldn't do it
[Laughter]
your price is 500k for your kids no no i
wanna you know what i would go high i
would go really [ __ ] high like
anthony how can you how can you not sell
your [ __ ] hypothetical kid that you
don't even have yet i'll sell the [ __ ]
out of myself i'm a sentimental ass
[ __ ] you [ __ ] up into a gymboree
though there's so many [ __ ] kids out
there you guys are thinking like my kids
worth 300 million people over your [ __ ]
just get over yourself you know how many
dudes [ __ ] abandon their kids for
free yes this is better you guys name
everyone else's price that's what you
name are your price for my kids 8k
especially if luna's down
no honestly
6 500. 6 500. okay that's pretty good
yeah that's under market value though
you could go to the adoption center the
ears are going to come out how did the
ears come out i don't know enough to
know yeah that's what i'm gonna earn
these ones my ear but my baby's kid
their ears are gonna be huge do you
swear what that the ears are gonna come
out here they're gonna be huge yeah fine
if i could go to the adoption center and
in the top dollar
all right
is 50 grand joe's kids paying to get
taken away
please take them here
what makes you guys think that you can
outsell the premium place if you go to
adoption center that's just like going
to hermes that's the top-notch adoption
turn your head to that weight well you'd
say this 250 million that's crazy
when you're going to adopt yourself
you're going to a shelter
but at an adoption center
yeah exactly yeah dude you're getting
some snarling rape rabid kid dude you
know what i do okay you know what i do
to save a little bit of money you know
what i do save a little bit of money i
go up to auntie lee and i go
i take a little bit of his hair i take
some [ __ ] nina's hair and i make my
own baby and i [ __ ] save 250 million
dollars are you [ __ ] kidding me
because they're idiots how the [ __ ] did
you make a baby with hair two women too
you cloned two women you don't know
about the genome yeah the human genome
project
oh my god get over yourself why didn't i
think of this [ __ ] she wants money okay
so they're willing to pay 250 right
that's how much you can buy a plate for
you right
yeah you can but that's 250 bucks
that's tempting you buy a kid at the
adoption center for 50 grand yeah you
[ __ ] hold the kid in walmart same
[ __ ] comes up to you
250 bam i'll give you it for 250. you
just made 200 000 business and you go
back to the doctor for round two round
two that's so good you take the 200 you
buy four more
no no you take the 200 you buy a prop
job cessna
okay you take it to cuba cuba you
[ __ ] sell that [ __ ] for cash yeah you
buy a kid hopefully you can get back out
yeah you can't you sell the kid for a
plane
i think we'll find the kid i've got it
i'm telling you
something coconuts got it joe's onto
something with this [ __ ] almost it's a
super [ __ ] okay we're so close we just
don't there's something missing
the kid back in the morals
yeah i couldn't either
you